Steve Bannon thank you very much for
joining thank you for coming out thank
you thank you for coming here in a
Michigan to our border Alan our pleasure
you are here yeah to ask for private
funding to build the wall yes is that
not in itself proof of president Trump's
failure to get this job done to fulfill
that campaign promise that's not a
failure remember it is a process he's
got to fulfill it or essentially die
trying I mean this is why he's lucky
he's called for something pretty
extraordinary to call for an emergency
order to basically say I'm calling this
a crisis and I'm going to take other
other resources from Department defense
in other places to get the Army Corps of
Engineers down there is extraordinary in
its own right
you say it's extraordinary what Donald
Trump is done but isn't it extraordinary
because there is no crisis this is
fabricated there's no emergency we have
a crisis 2017 we don't give all the
happy topspin numbers here's here's
around we have it know the facts are we
have a failed narco-state half of Mexico
is run by the cartels the traffic coming
in across those voters they're coming
through the legal go absolutely not
that's what the ones they catch are the
ones that coming across the border talk
to the Border Patrol who are the number
one people that answer the wall the
border patrol and ice and now homeland
security saying in 2017 there were
record low numbers of illegal crossings
you can't just discount that no no we
now have a bigger price on the border
we've ever had with drugs with
criminality
with the refugee problem the Micra
problem and this is a don't support
absolutely not true let's move on Russia
you're a witness of fact I know there's
a limit to what you can say but you had
time with Muller
you've been questioned by below you have
a unique insight in that respect so is
it a hoax
is it a witch hunt what or is it a
legitimate investor
I'm the person that arguments been
publicly stated I argue against firing
Coleman I thought it was stupid because
I thought the Russian clears things a
joke to see if the investigation you've
seen I said once I said I said I said
from day one if they named a special
prosecutor it is what it is you're gonna
have to play by the rules I think Bob
mola is a nice thing is a very
respectable guy he's up he's a combat
veteran Marine Corps veteran he's
renowned to the FBI
I think he's run this process now it's
taken two years I have said from day one
if Roger stone and WikiLeaks is all you
got on Russian collusion you have enough
Trump says no collusion you said the
Trump town meeting was treasonous are
you concerned that Robert Mullen I don't
think it's going to say that collusion
went all the way to the toe absolutely I
don't think they'll find I think that
that I think that means the in a day and
it be enough to burger it will take it
nothing burger now what they've got to
me and all the thing they've got they've
got Roger stone somehow not talking to
Julian they have a foreign adversary
offering dirt on an opponent and the
campaign saying yes please reopen I
think I took if you look at that thing
return to be one meeting and I don't
think I want anywhere from there who
knows look what I am and I said
professionals like Paul Manafort should
have known you'd never take a meeting
like that so you're saying it was wrong
it was stupid
okay we're stupid does that make it
criminal no far from it is make a
collusion a collusion thing you know
went to the top absolutely not
absolutely no way you don't think you
did on the inside surely something like
that would be okay without oh no no no
no no on the campaign on the campaign in
particularly before I got there they
were kind of running around that time
these are such a marginal things to
begin with right if that's where he's
gonna hang collusion on that's a pretty
thin reef so who's his biggest threat
which Democrats I think the ones he
should be least worried about are Bernie
Sanders and Joe Biden I just don't think
this old news I'd listen I think Camelot
Harris and award at least in the package
could potentially be the two best that
gets this that can mobilize the base and
running as a package California in Texas
and I think that's where a ticket right
now a combo of Camila Harrison or work
to be very powerful in here could be
truck hitting that could be Trump here's
why I think at the end of the one they
weigh and measure with about being
commander-in-chief and about do these
people have the gravitas I think on
paper they look good you're gonna have
to see how the campaign the one thing
the Democrats should be very nervous
about and I think that's why it's all
the polling shows about Joe Biden they
would like to have some sort of centrist
that relates to working-class people
okay that's what Biden represents I
think Biden Peaks I think the his
highest day is the day he announces who
is more influential to Donald Trump in
terms of brexit Nigel Farage of treasom
a Onoda fraction I think listen he does
that say about the special relationship
well he drew bond when she came over on
the directory somebody came over Trump
sat there and he totally says listen
number one overshoot the target on your
deal because it'll come apart you know
overshoot the target number two get on
with it you ought to be in terms agreed
in six months and number three he told
her use every to every error in your
quiver even if you have to do litigation
later she kind of laughed it off she
says oh she said to swim to be brutally
frank about it she's not terribly
sophisticated okay I don't think she
understood the complexity was going in
to Trump did I think I understood the
complexities of brexit more than treason
I think Trump understood as a deal guy
exactly what you have to do to put
forward a process that doesn't leave you
in three weeks ago with nothing would
Boris Johnson make a good Prime Minister
I think Boris Johnson wouldn't give you
privacy
she speaks room I have not talked him in
a while but I think Boris Johnson is a I
think more safe aspect I think I think
yeah definitely I think Boris Johnson's
a guy with big ideas I think he's now
the new recreated Boris Johnson that's
lost thirty pounds and his looks very
folks got a new haircut
he's a role model no I think Boris
Johnson role model for you and Roman
while the way he's lost so much weight
okay it's a new new free creative force
job
inspiring in a way I expected to very
inspiring yeah okay um some people who
follow you are white supremacists are
racist with Dangerous Ideas does that
concern you first off are you worried
about the first are first up I have done
I have done probably more than a bi to
say the ethno-nationalism are a bunch of
screwballs whether they're neo
Confederates neo Nazis all these guys
are clowns the ethno-nationalism dong
guys they have to me they have electrons
here they have no purpose in politics
deffenbaugh though it's just like in
Jeremy Corbyn he's got all kind of crazy
guys enough he can't help that right
here some of the guys he can't help but
there's some guys I'm left he can't help
it's the mainstream media that puts a
camera in front of these people and
gives them a platform do you miss the
White House no which is I took one year
in my life that camp 1 April oddest
August your oculus crusade surely the
best position to be in to further that
is the Oval Office not a Town Hall in
Detroit no absolutely not this is this
is I can go to Europe and go to Japan
I'm my own boss I can I can I can work
with the people I'd like the people I
think ever potential in the future that
White House is very hierarchical
can he get reelected oh yeah years oh
yeah absolutely didn't even he didn't he
did didn't mean didn't he be the first
that's very humble I haven't heard you
be quite so humble in the past he didn't
he didn't he meet it logged you'd best
candidate we ever had would you go back
if he asked ADA listen he's got a great
campaign team I had my one shot I'm out
here doing my thing I get five or six
ordinary she called you up and said
Steve I need you back on the track I
don't think I don't think I don't think
I'm gonna get that call so I don't a
speculator caught I'm not gonna get that
caught and he's gonna be fine without me
Steve Bannon thank you so much thank you
thank you for coming by the way thank
you for coming out here tonight thanks